imagine yourself standing before a 100
foot wave of ocean water
for most I'm guessing running to safety
would be the first instinct that would
kick in but for today's guest the
immediate thought is singular grab your
board and let's go surfing fear is you
know something that we choose something
we manufacture in our mind and it's when
we're thinking about the past or
thinking about the future and those two
things do not exist so if we fully
embrace the moment and just think about
where we are in that moment and do our
best in that moment sphere does not
exist I was just the guy who would just
put it on the line and so they thought
it was kind of crazy they didn't realize
it was calculated crazy
I just wanted sorry if the goal is to
keep surfing
there's nothing that we can't do if we
want if we put our mind to it